[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight we have stunning new
details for you on that horrifying
nursing home attack in detroit that we
showed you on friday night the story is
even worse than we realized
it turns out an executive order from
governor Gretchen Whitmer may have
played a role in what you saw we've got
two tales for you in just a moment
first tight though we hope you had a
happy Memorial Day weekend it's possible
you have spent along with millions of
others months trapped indoors per
government order so getting outside
makes all the difference grilling a
hamburger in the fresh air hitting the
park walking the beach for a couple of
hours it's essential all of us needed
nature is medicine happy balanced people
understand that intuitively you can't
just sit on a couch all day barking at
other people on social media your soul
will rot if you do that and
unfortunately it's too late for a lot of
people at CNN and they haven't even been
trapped inside for months for reasons
that no one in authority has ever really
explained cable news yappers have been
classified as essential workers from the
very first day of lockdown and by the
way that includes us it also includes
the partisan political activists on the
other channels they didn't lose their
jobs they have not been quarantined if
anything they are thriving in the midst
of this disaster they feel more
essential than they ever have your
suffering has been the best thing to
happen to them since impeachment when
they got to spend a full month
pretending to know where Ukraine is so
you can imagine their rage when they saw
you outdoors this weekend enjoying time
with your family the fact that you
disobeyed them drove them insane your
CNN these were not the images health
officials were hoping to see this
Memorial Day party goers ignoring social
distancing rules pack this pool in
Missouri over the weekend
beaches boardwalks pools packed with
many people who are not wearing masks
who are not socially distancing even as
health experts warn that if they don't
social distance there will be a spike in
coronavirus cases within the next two
weeks but the question about masks
take a look there isn't a single person
on the speech wearing one scenes of
crowded vacationers on a boardwalk in
Ocean City Maryland and at Myrtle Beach
South Carolina even a state start to
reopen I don't even like that term
reopening cause it symbolizes the
floodgates being opened can you imagine
people enjoying time outdoors with their
kids they should be as unhappy as we are
at CNN now this being CNN a lot of
people didn't actually hear any of that
most CNN viewers are hustling through
airports trying to make a flight that's
where the network traps the bulk of its
audience and the sound is often down
producers thought of that though
diabolical as they are so they made sure
to reinforce their message with graphics
on the screens crowds across us ignore
guidelines spearing fears of spread red
one spearing what a verb Memorial Day
crowds spark fear of new outbreaks read
another and then there was this one
Americans flocked to public places as
death toll nears a hundred thousand what
exactly does that mean
seen I never explained you should be
terrified that was the point so no
explanation was necessary over on MSNBC
the usual collection of retired CIA
analysts and assistant professors of
Gender Studies was terrified they feared
that somewhere out there in America
there might still be people who believed
in more than shopping and vacations or a
fine
it's possible they fretted that people
like this dangerous religious extremists
might somehow find each other and come
together to pray not pray to Tim Cook or
the Google twins in Silicon Valley or
even to Barack Obama but pray to
something called God and that cannot be
allowed the virus is not religious it
won't respond to prayer I'm afraid
aggressive reopening Zin defiance in
some instances of public health warnings
from his own CDC and his own advisers
and on the other side Democrats who have
seemingly hitched their fortunes to
science and data regardless of how that
plays with separation of church and
state and even if the president has
no authority to issue such a decree
Trump's insistence on a rushed reopening
flies in the face of what public health
experts continue to advise that this is
not a time to become complacent there
you have it
jeb Bush's dim-witted spokeswoman now
rebranded as an eminent epidemiologist
and she wants you to know that she
expects you to believe the Democrats put
these lockdown orders in place based on
quote science and data okay we'll take
the challenge what science and data are
you talking about exactly well wait as
you rifle through your papers and
abstracts dr. Wallace that could take a
while because in fact there is still no
science or data at all after two months
if these lock downs have done very much
to halt the spread of this virus sorry
we wish were otherwise you hate to think
of all those people suffering for no
reason but it's true
states that lock down early and
aggressively are no better off today on
average than states that never lock down
at all that's a fact those are the data
you're talking about and by contrast
there is an awful lot of science and
data that going outside is vital to your
health and has been for a hundred years
we've known that exercising outdoors
getting vitamin D from the Sun this
makes you healthier and less vulnerable
to coronavirus the virus also spreads
far less easily outdoors than it does
indoors again this is not speculation
its fact the largest study of this
subject ever done took a look at 318
separate coronavirus infection clusters
places where the virus spread outward to
other people what did it find it found
that at 317 out of 318 clusters
that's 99.7% the infection spread
indoors not outdoors indoors and indoors
is where dr. science and data on MSNBC
claims you must remain uh-huh so now CNN
and MSNBC are not bringing you science
and data they're peddling panic and
reckless moral judgment and it's having
an awful effect on this country this
footage illustrates the results of the
propaganda it's from a Staten Island
grocery store and
shows a woman attacked by other
customers for not wearing a mask
[Music]
you hate to see Americans treating each
other like that
but multiply what you just saw by an
entire country and you get a sense of
what the relentless flow of Lies has
done to people's minds and now we have
science and data on the subject a new
survey by the Census Bureau found that
more than one-third of all Americans now
show signs of anxiety depression or both
now you'd think the most fearful people
would be the ones most at risk and
that's people over 80 but just the
opposite turns out to be true younger
people are more miserable the younger
the more miserable in fact the most
miserable group of all is Americans
under 30 and that group look at the
science and data face virtually no risk
of dying from this virus none the people
on television have lied to them and it's
wrecking their lives meanwhile the
people on television themselves are just
fine
they don't seem afraid Andrew Cuomo's
brother works at CNN he had the virus a
while back he didn't bother to
quarantine when he had it he told you he
was but he didn't he got in his car and
drove to his second home and wandered
around with no mask on then he went back
on television and shattered it you for
not wearing a mask
uh-huh in Michigan over this past
weekend governor Gretchen Whitmer's
husband decided to violate his own
wife's orders by traveling across the
state to use his boat hey it's Memorial
Day when the marina told him they could
not put the boat in the water
Gretchen Whitmer's husband let them know
that his wife was the governor don't you
know who I am
he got caught of course people really
resent that kind of behavior from their
leaders and they should and when
confronted at first Gretchen Whitmer
governor Whitmer tried to claim it never
happened she dismissed the whole thing
as an Internet hoax but it wasn't a hoax
she was lying now she's saying was all
some kind of joke yeah pretty funny but
if you really want to know what the
people on television think of you and
think of their own
Krypton's for you and if you want to
know whether all the huffing and puffing
and the moralizing and the judging you
is real
watch this clip it's from MSNBC and the
people they're just not worried about it
Calla they're not worried about their
own personal safety I haven't met
anybody who is I think people felt like
the supreme court made the decision here
in Wisconsin that it was time to open up
you can see here just around nobody's
wearing them
nobody's striking images Oh busted
busted turns around to hassle some guy
to Packer Jersey oh look at guys don't
wearing a mask and the guy in the
Packers jersey calls him out and says
your camera's not wearing a mask Dumbo
you fraud they are frauds remember that
the next time they tell you you're
immoral